[Musique]
enfin bon jour les enfants
vous avez été bien sage et warhol -
qu'est-ce que tu as demandé à noël
non non non non romains à la place tu
vas avoir une intoxication alimentaire
une brûlure au troisième degré et une
gueule de bois en chêne massif
[Musique]
voilà ça y est on y est c'est noël vous
avez tout prévu le champagne est au
frais le vin blanc aussi le vin rouge
non mais il n'est pas loin quand même
les beatles sont au frigo les
invitations ont été lancées les cadeaux
ont été commandé sur amazon bref vous
avez tout prévu tous non à soirée
exceptionnelle galère exceptionnel noël
regorge de danger inattendu
voici un petit tour d'horizon de ce qui
pourrait vous arriver et comment
l'éviter ou de comment limiter la casse
les pompiers et mes anciens collègues du
samu et vous le diront c'est un grand
classique des fêtes de noël le sapin
profond et en quelques secondes tout le
salon et tout le reste eh oui parce
qu'un sapin ça brûle très vite surtout
ceux avec la fausse neige mais les
autres aussi pour éviter les drames
évitez de placer le vôtre à côté d'une
source de chaleur comme une lampe un
radiateur une cheminée ou votre belle
soeur si vous tenez absolument à mettre
une guirlande clignotante à l'intérieur
choisissez en une qui respectent les
normes européennes
ne la laissez pas allumée en permanence
et en tout cas jamais son surveillant le
soir de noël ne laissait pas non plus
tati josette sans surveillance empêcher
la d'allumer son cierges magiques juste
à côté du sapin
vous savez comment allaient quand elle a
vu un tout à fait mauvais
on en a déjà parlé mais c'est le soir
idéal pour en remettre une petite couche
il faut y penser avant parce que mieux
vaut prévenir que guérir
alors idéalement il faudrait voir de
façon raisonnable mais bon je vous
connais alors voici les huit
commandements contre la gueule de bois
ne commencez pas avoir le ventre vide
buvait du bon si vous pouvez buvez un
verre d'eau entre chaque verre d'alcool
pour éviter la déshydratation a et
mettez une bouteille d'eau à côté de
votre lit avant de commencer la soirée
après vous ne ferez pas le lendemain
prenez un citrate de bétaïne ça vous
permettra de boire et de manger
sereinement ne restez pas à jeun manger
trop gras mais mangez buvez de l'eau de
l'eau et prenez une bonne douche chaude
est allé faire un tour
allez vous balader bon c'est pas de la
magie mais ça limitera les dégâts
si vous êtes du genre à manger des
animaux vivants et que vous avez gardé
la nostalgie de l'époque où vous mangez
vos crottes de nez noël c'est l'occasion
de déguster et peut ensuite bien grasset
avant de les manger faut les ouvrir et
avant de les ouvrir souvent il a eu la
paieront la blessure au couteau à
huîtres c'est d'ailleurs l'un des motifs
les plus répandues de consultation aux
urgences les soirs de réveillon de base
ouvrir des huîtres à ouvrir des huîtres
avec un couteau
parce que les huîtres ouverture facile
ça marche aussi bien que tous les trucs
ouverture facile de base donc ouvrir des
huîtres c'est pas facile alors ouvrir
des huîtres
après la paieront si vous ne voulez pas
reprendre le plafond avec votre artères
radial regarder des tuto sur la façon
d'ouvrir des huîtres et fait ça avant
l'apéro n'hésitez pas à protéger la main
qui tient l'huître avec un gros gants ou
avec un torchon plié petite astuce si
vous exposer les huîtres à la chaleur
genre quelques secondes au micro-ondes
elles vont s'entrouvrir et ce sera plus
facile mais je vous préviens les
puristes vont gueuler
non non non
le truc avec les huit c'est qu'une fois
ouverte et dévoré vivent ma des fois et
se venge une petite toxi infection et
hop et versailles le problème c'est que
c'est relativement imprévisible mais ya
quand même quelques précautions de bon
sens
achetez les au dernier moment dans un
commerce auquel vous faites confiance
vérifier la date de conditionnement sur
l'étiquette conserver les biens aux
frais et vérifier qu'elles sont bien
vivantes avant de les manger dans le
doute cette pâle et ont un petit conseil
vous savez la bouteille d'eau vous avez
mis à côté de votre ligne était une
bassine à côté parce que si malgré tout
ça vous arrive
vu que vous êtes 12 et qui a qu'un seul
chiottes vous serez bien content de la
trouver
cela va sortir de partout un autre grand
classique des services d'urgence les
soirs de noël
l'intoxication mais au monoxyde de
carbone cette fois en cause un mode de
chauffage vieillot inadaptés ou une
cheminée qui turbinent toute la soirée
et qu'il est insidieusement le gaz
envahir la pièce le problème c'est qu'il
est inodore et que quand on s'en rend
compte
à cause des nausées des maux de tête ou
d'un violent coup de barre est bien
c'est qu'on est déjà intoxiqué les deux
conseils à suivre fait entretenir votre
chauffage et ramenez votre cheminée et
le soir même aérer régulièrement la
pièce
comme noël ça doit rester une fête je
vais pas vous faire le vrai inventaire
de tout ce qui pourrait arriver ce soir
là et avoir conscience du danger
ça peut servir à être prêts à intervenir
en cas de brûlure par exemple parce que
même sans parler du sapin cela va
s'activer en cuisine et ça peut mal
tourner en cas d'étouffement aussi
admettons citati josette à un peu trop
hâte de finir sa dinde pour passer à la
bûche ou en cas d'hémorragie big up à
toutes les ut qui se laisse pas faire
pour noël vous pouvez aussi demander une
formation gestes qui sauvent on joue
mais les liens dans la description comme
dame dans tous les cas n'oubliez pas le
réflexe numéro un
appeler le samu au 15 ou les pompiers au
18 ou le numéro d'urgence européen 112
vous orientera vers la personne la mieux
placée pour vous conseiller ou pour vous
envoyer une équipe adaptée à votre cas
bon désolé mais on peut pas se quitter
sans en parler c'est le truc qui sont
ici par excellence de deux choses l'une
soit vous allez pas voir là c'est ok
mais n'oubliez pas quand même que les
autres sur la route ils seront peut-être
pas aussi raisonnable que vous soit vous
allez boire et on va pas se mentir vous
allez boire au delà de la limite légale
dans ces cas là on est d'accord
vous ne conduisez pas vous prévoyez le
coup une chambre d'amis un canapé lit un
matelas dans un coin vous vous
débrouillez vous dormez sur place si
c'est pas possible et que vous tenez
absolument à rentrer chez vous faites
vous raccompagner un capitaine de soirée
un taxi en vtc ça coûte pas un bras et
ça peut sauver vos deux ans à huy a
évidemment tout ça c'est valable pour le
réveillon de noël et pour le réveillon
du jour de l'an
romain et moi on vous souhaite de très
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année rendez vous
après les festivités du sila mettez vous
bien et surtout portez vous bien
exactement
[Musique]